- This is what I find interesting,
so you were actually about to quit acting
right before you got
"Schitt's Creek," right?
- Yes, just before "Schitt's
Creek" things were quite bleak.
My house had just burnt down,
I had like $3 in my bank
account, things were,
I hadn't worked in close to two years
and I had just blown my
very first screen test,
like blown it, blown
it, blown it, blown it.
And I found myself crying
in the Pacific Ocean,
a very snotty cry.
And the universe was like,
"Don't do this anymore!
"This is not for you."
But then two days later,
I got the audition for "Schitt's Creek."
(all applauding)
(audience cheering)
- I love that you tell this story though,
because a lot of people
wouldn't tell that.
And I think it's really cool
because I do have friends that are actors
and it's a very hard job.
It's either you're like really winning
or you're just like really gone.
And same thing in music,
but it's just really cool
that you're open about it,
'cause everybody goes
through those moments
where you're like, "Oh my gosh,
like, should I move on
or should I do this?"
And I love that you're open about it.
I also love that you're hilarious
and in one of my favorite
shows of all time.
- Thanks, thanks, Kelly Clarkson.
- It's so great.